We will now transition to Human resources.
Since we are more than an hour behind, we are foregoing our break
to be respectful of department representatives. So we're
self sacrificing today.
We do have a few snacks if you'd like,
but I'm helping with you all with the weight loss program for the
of Houston. As HR is here,
who's running the department.
It's just like a machine, right?
Absolutely. Well oiled. I love it. I love it.
That's how well we do it. Yes.
At this time, I'd like to welcome Director Jane Cheeks and Carla Coleman
as they will provide the human Resource department budget presentation.
Good to have you. Thank you very much. And I apologize in advance,
of course. I know we apologize to you for I get horse on the day
that I have to present, but Carla has
my back. I want to thank you all and good
afternoon, Chair and Vice Chair and Council members.
I, along with Carla Coleman, assistant Director of HR
Finance, are pleased today to present
our FY 23 HR
budget presentation. I'm also enjoying by
my executive staff, which I'll introduce shortly.
The city of Houston has over 21,000
employees and HR touches every one of
them. Whether it's facilitating health and wellness,
enhancing workplace safety, providing opportunities
for training and development, caring for injured workers,
working towards pay equity or recruitment,
and onboarding, we never forget
the human element of our department's
name. Our primary purpose is to
provide opportunities for transformational public service
careers in an efficient and cost effective
manner, all while complying with a variety of
local, state and federal mandates.
Next slide please.
Next slide please. As you can see from our organizational
structure, I have ten divisions. We will be discussing
them more in detail further in the presentation.
But let me pause for 2 seconds just to introduce my team.
Elisa Franklin Brocks is my chief of staff.
Darren Hilton is my deputy director of HR operations.
Carla Coleman is my chief financial officer. Charles Smith
is my assistant Director of Risk Management.
Veronica Davis is my assistant Director of Benefits.
Katina Swift is my chief learning officer.
Velma Laws is the assistant chief policy officer.
Abdi Sdecki is my deputy assistant Director over
Human Resources Information Management. Bob Johnson
is my compensation manager. And Leslie Denton
roach is over HR Communications. And I
would be remiss if I didn't introduce Aisha Roberts as
the Deputy Assistant director over HR operations.
And Stefan Mahal. He's the deputy assistant
director. Director over risk management. I also have the
team that tirelessly helped me put this benefits budget
together. So Carla, would you introduce your team? Yes, my team,
please stand up. The financial team, please stand
up. I can't hear you, I'm sorry. So this is
the core team that actually worked late nights in putting this budget
numbers together. So without them, I wouldn't be able to present here today.
So I thank you and I acknowledge the hard work that they put
in. Thank you, Taylor. Thank you.
Next slide, please.
This slide shows a diverse range of statutes which
we must comply to. Our goal is to administer
all compliance initiatives in a manner that minimizes
risk and maximizes compliance with each statute,
thus shielding the city from potential penalties
and legal cost.
Mayor Turner often speaks about incrementalist.
He states we should be transformational.
We made some major strides here in the HR
Department department in FY 22, one being
the passage of the Prenatal Parental and Infant Wellness
Ordinance. The next one will be one of our largest
projects, the HR One project,
which is a collaboration with Director Kent and the Hits
team and Director Piyas in the Payroll team, where we
will implement Success Factors and Employee central.
We are also implementing a new platform,
Benefits Focus, for our benefits administration.
We will make history with the Benefit Focus implementation
by finally ridding our valued retirees
of a paper intensive process of electing
and changing their benefits. Both Success
Factors and Benefit Focus will offer the
mobility function which is crucial in our digital
transformation.
Another major project in HR is zero is
possible. It's called zip. Our safety program.
We have been instrumental in leading safety from top to
bottom by providing all employees, from directors
to frontline workers, with the understanding that zero
accidents are truly possible.
We are also implementing several new technical services to
assist us in providing a higher level of customer service,
such as analytical data through power
bi. Next slide.
With our strong commitment to technological advancement,
the footprint we will leave on our organization
will be a model of how HR should conduct business
in municipalities for years to come.
Today we will present our FY proposed budget.
We have reviewed the services that HR
provides to our client department and
integrated all the HR functions residing
in the General Fund into our Central Services Revolving Fund.
The mayor's higher Houston youth program will be the
only thing that will remain in our general fund.
This will allow more efficiency,
more efficient delivery of services for
HR. Now I will turn the
presentation over to my CFO to discuss the budget further.
Thank you, Director Cheeks. And good afternoon,
Chair. Vice Chair. Mayor Per term and council members.
So, what you have in front of you is the functional
chart for HR, which is proposed a budget of $514,000,000
and it funds 448.7
FTEs. And this is done through five funds.
We have a General fund, two revolving funds and two
Internal Services Fund. In the General Fund,
we are proposing a budget of 1.5 million to fund 152.7
FTE for the Hara Houston Youth Program.
Then in the revolving funds, we have the Central Service Revolving Fund,
which the proposed budget is 38 million
and it funds 185 FTE and
the budget is 8% of the combined HR
budget. Then the other revolving fund is the Workers Compensation
Fund, which the proposed budget is 45 million. And it
funds 60 FTEs and it represents 9%
of the combined HR budget. And then
from the Internal Revenue Internal Services Fund we
have the Health Benefit Fund which is budgeted at 428,000,000 and
it funds 51 FTEs and it represents 85%
of HR's budget. And lastly the Long Term
Disability Fund which is budgeted at 1.6 million,
represents less than 1% of the HR's
budgeted fund and it doesn't have any personnel associated
with it. Next slide please.
This is the functional chart for the General Fund
and as I mentioned, the only thing funded here is the Har
Houston Youth for 1.5 million and
it funds 152.7 FTEs or
509 positions. We have expecting 500
interns and nine career coaches. Next slide
please. This is the central
revolving fund for HR and the proposed budget is $38 million
and it funds 185 FTEs
in seven divisions. We are integrating
the HR General Funds operational functions
into this fund, so we are funding 185
FTEs. In addition to the HR functions,
core functions that this budget holds, we also have
the budget for contingent workforce and for the training
and organizational development of the city.
Next slide please.
This is the Workers Compensation Fund and the proposed budget is
45 million and it funds 60 FTEs
and three major functions managed by two divisions.
The Safety and the Workers compensation functions are
managed by the HR Risk Management Division and their
mission is to create a safe work environment by eliminating workplace
hazard, reducing the financial impact associated with
the workplace injuries and by being advocates to our injured workers.
Next slide please.
This is the Health Benefit Fund and the proposed budget
is 428,000,000 and it funds 51
FTEs and four major functions managed
by four divisions. This budget houses all the
benefit plans for the city which includes the medical
and the pharmacy plans, the supplemental plans such as dental,
vision, life insurance, life dependent
care, flexible spending and two Medicare Advantage
plans for retirees over 65. Next slide please.
And the long term disability fund, which is budgeted
at 1.6 million. It doesn't have any personnel associated with
it and this fund is mostly determined by an annual actuary
evaluation and it happens at year end.
Next slide please. Now this
is the revenue slide for most departments and
this chart compares the proposed budget for next fiscal
year with this current year's estimate.
So I want to say that HR is not a revenue generating
department, so our revenues are products of chargebacks
to the departments for actual program and services and
based on utilization. And also it's a product
of contribution from employees, retirees and city departments.
So this chart shows an increase of 9.5% or
45 million. Next slide please.
Now this slide covers the key drivers that increases
the proposed revenues, but they are the same key drivers that are
actually increasing the expense sites. So we'll talk about them
later in the expense sites because they're exactly the same as we're not
a revenue generating department. Next slide please.
So this is the expend budget for HR and
this chart compares the FY 23 proposed budget
with this year's current budget. And as you can
see, the 23 budget is proposed
with an increase of 23 million or 4.7%.
Next slide please.
This slide actually has the key drivers for both
the revenue and the expenses. And this
23 million is broken down as follows. So we
see first the General Fund that has a decrease of 2.5 million,
or 62.1%, and mainly this is to
the merger of the HR operations activities and the
General Fund with a Central Service Revolving Fund. So the only thing
left in the General fund is the har Houston youth.
Then the next thing we have is the Central Revolving Fund
which increased by 6.9 million or 20%,
and the increases are due to increased utilization
in temporary service personnel. And we also added this year
the fire department officer ranking exam for captain
and senior captain. We also have personnel increases
due to hope and benefits as well as cost increases for technology
initiatives that Director Cheeks mentioned earlier.
The Workers Compensation Fund increased by 6.1 million or
15%, mostly due to catastrophic high claims related to
COVID. We also have personnel increases in this fund as
well. And then the health benefit increase of 13 million
or 3.1 is mostly due to premium rate increases of
6.5% from 3.4% last year.
We also have high claim cost in this fund related
to COVID and personnel increases across the board for
benefits and hope. And then the long term disability also has
an increase in rates which increased the budget by
85,000 or 5%. But the increase is mostly due to
participation count increases which drives the claim
increases as well. Next slide, please.
Now in the next six slides we're going to see the HR's budget allocated
between personnel and non personnel cost.
In this slide in front of you, you have the proposed budget combined budget
of 514,000,000. It allocates 7%
of this budget to personnel to fund 448.7
FTEs and this is done with $34 million.
Then the 93% remaining of the budget goes to non personnel
expenses or other expenses for 480,000,000.
Out of this, 480,000,076% is
allocated to claim expenses for the benefit
funds. Then 11% goes to
other health benefit plans which includes supplemental plans and retirees
plans. Then it goes to Workers Compensation claims for 8% and
the remaining of the budget goes to other services, supplies and
restricted accounts. Next slide please.
This one is the allocation of the General Fund budget for Har Houston
Youth, and it allocates 98% of its budget to personnel
to fund 152.7 FTEs,
or 509 positions, and the remainder of
the budget of 31,000. You find it allocated
to other services and supplies. Next slide please.
The revolving funds budget which is set at 38 million,
allocates 53% of that budget to personnel to
fund 185 FTEs and
then the remaining 47% to fund the other person
non personnel cost of 18 million. Out of this,
18,000,087% of that goes to
other services for 16 million and the remainder goes to restricted
accounts and supplies. Next slide
please. The workers compensation
fund budgeted at 45 million. Allocates 15%
of that budget to personnel for 60 FTEs
and then 85% goes to non personnel expenses.
And out of this 38 million, which is represent 85%,
97% of that is just claims experience and the
remainder you will find in other services, restricted and supplies,
which is just 13% of that budget.
Next slide please.
Here you see the health benefit which is budgeted $428,000,000.
Only 1% of that budget is allocated to personnel for
only 50 funding, 51 FTEs. The rest of this budget,
which is 422, 87% of
that is allocated to health benefit claims,
then 12% of that is allocated to the other health
benefit plans, supplemental plans and retirees, and the
remainder goes to other services, restricted accounts and supplies.
Next slide please. Lastly, we have the
Long term Disability Fund which has no personnel
associated with it. So 98% of the
1.6 proposed budget goes to fund claims
expenses and the other 2% goes to TPA fees and
actuarial service at the end of the year. Next slide
please. This is
the net change for the General Fund for HR. And as you can see,
HR for this fiscal year has two components,
the operational budget and the Har Houston Youth Program.
This budget was reduced by a net reduction of 20,000
for adjustments to restricted account, hope and health benefit.
It further has a reduction of 2.5
and that is to merge the operational activities
in the General Fund into the Central Service Revolving Fund.
And the only thing left in this budget is 1.5,
which funds the higher Houston youth. So the net change from 22
to 23 is a reduction of 62.1%.
Next slide and council
members, this concludes the financial presentations for the budget
at HR, but I pass back to Director Cheese for closing remarks.
Thank you. Thank you, Carla.
Thank you, Carla. I like to thank my executive staff
and every HR employee for the hard work they put
in continuously each day to service our client
departments and council members. I'd like to thank
you also, thank you for supporting us as we continue
to optimize our HR journey. Do you have any
questions for us today? Yes. Council member Abby Cayman.
Thank you, Mayor Pro TEM. First off, Director, to you and your
entire team. Thank you. It has certainly not
been an easy few years. I was looking back over the
accomplishments that you listed and
even when I approached you a few years ago, one parental
leave, which is a massive accomplishment, but even including additional
insurance program benefits like healthy
babies, healthy pregnancy. But on top of all of that,
you dealt with COVID you dealt with implementing a system for
testing for the city you had to deal with. We talked about NIT
Kronos and those issues challenge after challenge after
challenge, and you all continue to serve. So thank you for that. I also just
wanted to, again, just spotlight
my appreciation for you as a director.
You always take our calls. You work with us, of course,
under Mayor Turner's leadership. But thank you for pushing the ball
forward for the city in leading the way again as
a city for the entire country.
It's phenomenal. And again, to your entire staff, I'm looking at a few in particular.
It's just a pleasure to work with you all. So congratulations. Thank you.
And I forgot to ask my department question that
I ask everyone. Due to the financial constraints
currently faced by the city of Houston, what are needs that are
not addressed in this budget that you would like us to be aware of?
What needs that are not?
Wow.
Council Member, I want to tell you, I'm sure everybody
is having staffing issues. And at the end of
the day, HR is not the
same for HR. We are diligently trying
to staff our vacancies, and that's
just something that is challenging not only
for the city, but throughout the United States right
now. So we continue to just
make sure that we provide the highest level of customer service,
but we'll continue to staff up. Well, again, I appreciate
everything in the partnership. Thank you. Thank you. Council Member
Michael Kubosh director Cheeks. This has been a real
tough two years for me and my wife. Yes,
sir. And you know it. Yes, sir. And you
were there. You always took my call.
Yes, sir. You always helped me. And I'm grateful
to you and your staff because it's been a tough
time. I broke my leg. My wife's had four surgeries,
been rough. And I appreciate because
a lot of times I don't know the inner workings of how it
goes. So I just go to you. Yes, sir. Then you
may say, well, and you've never said, I'm not the one to go to on
this. You just fix it. You help me get it together. And I'm
forever grateful for it. And I'm thankful
that you're the head of this department at
this time in my life. God bless you and thank you for your service to
our city. And I thank all of you with
Human resources. Council Member Sally Alcorn.
Thank you, chair in the Central Service Revolving Fund, the $12.3
million in contingent workforce contracts, can you describe
what those are specifically? The one for the general fund.
Go ahead. So we have two contracts, one for
the general fund, one for special revolving fund. We established that
last year when we saw the need of grant funded
departments actually incurring more staffing and
we had budget constraints. So according to
those budget constraints and their
operational needs, that's why it's increasing.
So primarily COVID related then? Well, at the beginning,
it was COVID related. We have a lot of grants that are still COVID related
for some departments. Okay. I might ask for some more details on
that. In the health benefits fund, the increase
$25 a month, I believe, in the limited plan. Is that
just in the Kelsey plan that employees will be paying $25
a month more to address the 6.5% increase, or are
those across all plans? So the
$25 surcharge, you're talking about $25
as it's described, for the limited plan. So,
yes, it's across the board. Yes,
ma'am. That's an additional additional towards the premium
that employees will pay in the next year to address
the rise in those costs. Yes, ma'am. And that will be the first time in
three years, council Member or Alcorn, that we have
actually had a charge to the employees,
because up until now we have done zero
for the employees. Okay. So the city has been absorbing any
increases and this is passing that one. Okay. I understand $12 on the health
surcharge. There is a line item with the health surcharge, $2.9 million.
What is that? So those are expenses that
we budget for any
wellness revenues that we receive. And so as we receive it,
we have to expense them. So that's what you see in that line item.
I'm not sure I understand that answer. We're calling it a
health surcharge. $2.9 million,
expense of the account. But those are expenses
that we're budgeting for any wellness.
So there's a revenue component to that equals two expenses.
So if there's any wellness revenue that we receive for
health assessments not completed okay, that's where I was going.
That's people that did not complete their health assessments,
$2.9 million worth of people that didn't do that.
Where's the spouse surcharge? Line item? It's included
in the revenue in the contribution side. For the revenue side,
I'd like to get an amount for that spouse surcharge that we're getting
annually. Thank you. I'll submit the rest online.
Thank you. Director Chiefs, I'll ask a question I sort
of asked the other day when we had our five year forecast and some of
the challenges that we're seeing, not only in the city
of Houston and corporate America, as well as workforce challenges
trying to get new employees, trying to maintain existing
employees.
I'm sure you get involved in a lot of pre employment
interviews and hopefully you're getting involved in a lot of exit
interviews to find out why people are leaving and going elsewhere if
they choose that option. When you talk to people back
years ago when the workforce was a little bit
different and pre COVID, I think a lot of things have changed.
And the reason why I'm saying that I'm trying to figure out when you
interview potential applicants, and I'll ask your department
leaders for this as well, and when you talk to folks about
why they're leaving the city of Houston and going elsewhere,
there's a number of dynamics that come into play.
Salary, vacation.
Some are looking for travel opportunities maybe that they don't
get here at the city of Houston. And family life balance
issues. One of the things we addressed just about a month ago
with parental leave and things like that, that will go a long way to
have us maintain and attract employees.
Where do you see retirement benefits come
into play when you talk to prospective employees
or employees that are leaving to go to corporate America?
That's a very good question. You specifically said
retirement benefits. So in my conversations
with respect to retirement benefits, they are not normally
the driving factor for those individuals that are leaving the city.
Most of the individuals that are actually coming into the city,
sir, they are looking at our salary and our benefits.
A lot of people leaving private sector are attracted to our
benefits. One, because believe it or not, they are cheaper.
They are cheaper than what individuals are paying right out of their pocket in
the private sector, especially because of what the city contributes
to those to that. But as far as the retirement,
we are millennials and I say that do not give them a
bad rap. They are employees
who want to work and they work very hard.
They're looking for their money and they're looking to get paid.
And retirement is not something that they're looking at
right away. Let me say it like that.
In my world, people look
for salary,
family life balance with proper vacation, medical coverage,
et cetera, and other issues
related to give me my money today and give me a comfortable
living today where I can do things and have the opportunity
to have some time off and spend with my wife
or my husband when we have kids.
And I believe that the way we look at the
next 30 years with our long term liability in the city,
it's going to continue to grow. And the
only way to not have it grow is to move to a different
blended type retirement plan. But when you
do that and you have the ability to start reducing your expenses,
this is something that's going to happen over the next 30 to 40 years
when a lot of folks like me will be in
another world and not collecting the
retirement pay that we collected or other employees.
So if you address the employees who are buying salary,
who are buying family life and are not buying
retirement, aren't we losing when
we don't raise salaries to compensate for a decrease
on the benefit side? The benefits being the
retirement pay, the defined contribution
benefit plan versus moving to some type of a blended
401 or what other states and cities around the United
States are doing in the government sector.
It's a question, but I think it's a question we need to explore
because if our young millennials, as you call them,
are not buying defined benefits and
are buying give me more money today and let me manage my
retirement. We're selling stuff they're not buying,
thus they're not going to come to us. Thus they're going to leave to go
to corporate America where guess what? They will be dealing with 401,
not defined benefits. So my
argument on this, and before I leave in a year and a half, I'd love
to understand what drives the
employees of the city of Houston today. And if it's because they
have a defined benefit plan, I'll be the first
one to say we'll stick with it. But I don't think they're buying what we're
selling. They're not buying the defined benefit. They're buying
give me more money today, give me a good family life balance, I want some
good vacation and I want parental leave when I have kids for
twelve weeks or whatever that is.
What do you think? You see it every day. You're the Director of HR.
I'm not. Well, let me tell you that our pension
is very attractive, sir. And how many different pension plans
do we have for employees that are working today? Is it four or five?
It's four. It's four different plans? Yes, we have four different
plans. So the defined benefit is still good.
Let me tell you just give me 2 seconds or two minutes. No,
you have all the time in the world. No, I know you all are.
We're only running late by an hour and a half. But that's okay. What I
definitely want to emphasize is that I might have answered that
a little bit different two years ago before COVID came.
Okay. All right, I might have answered that. So before
COVID hit, we pre COVID, we did not
have that many people retiring. When COVID started,
we had two to 3% more people retiring.
They were like, Listen, we're going to leave now.
But one thing I want to tell you that really affected this,
even the millennials, is that people now
are looking at their family life different because people
died. Vice Mayor Pro TEM and they're looking at
their coworkers that are no longer here. Mothers,
fathers, sisters, brothers, all of them. They're looking
at the fact that they need
to look at work differently. And I don't believe that
it's the defined benefit.
We have done well with the administration raising up our salaries,
stabilizing the pension, and doing all of those things.
What's most important right now to a lot of
people, not just the people that are just coming to the city,
it is truly being able to have that flexibility
here in the workplace. And I want to tell you that the
pension is still very appeasing to
even millennials. It's just that COVID
actually changed the way people think.
Right now, individuals are looking at our benefits from
having more mental stability within the workplace.
Our benefits are making a difference.
Our wellness is making a difference. And that
is actually attracting people because wellness is big
in the private sector. So when they come and see how
robust our wellness program is, how they're looking at
our benefits and how we pay such close
attention to the mental stability of our employees,
that is very important. Because right now in
the United States, how we look at mental stability,
whether you are young, whether you are middle aged,
or you are more tenured, that is something that is being
paid attention to. Vice Mayor Pro TEM she's
the Vice Mayor Pro TEM I know,
but my thing is we have four separate retirement plans.
What about studying a fifth plan? And that fifth plan will be,
if you don't value retirement play on the fine benefit
side, then I'm not going to give it to you, but I'm going to pay
you X percent more,
5%, 10%.
What are people going to do? What will people choose my
age? They're going to choose a defined benefit, of course. But I
think the new employees that we're getting aren't valuing again,
what we're selling, we're selling that we can give them more on the
base side and this thing will soften
out in a number of years as you have those employees
that retire and move away from the defined benefit plan.
But anyway, thank you. Just things to discuss.
I'd love to have a consultant look at it and see how this plays
not only in the other government arenas, but also in relationship
to where are we losing the people to? Are we losing them to Harris
County? Are we losing them to Chevron?
Who are we losing them to and why are we not competitive?
Is it salary that's driving them? Because they're surely
not going to leave because we have a
great salary package. Maybe they'll stay for the defined benefit. Council Member
Pollard thank you, Mayor Pro tim,
I think that's an interesting point that you're making, and I think based on
an individual's perspective on how they look at their
own life trajectory and their own savings and their own current
lifestyle and what they may choose. So I think that is interesting from
an HR perspective, though, we keep hearing, like the great
resignation. Does the city of Houston
put forth non competes for new hires?
So if a person comes in in a certain department,
are we able to put forth a non compete clause or
a mandatory stay clause that if you get hired
here, you must stay for X amount of time, or if
you do leave, you cannot take another job
in a similar field? Are we allowed to do that? Do we do that?
We have worked with the legal department on first of
all, let me answer the question. No, we do not have that in the human
Resources department. There have been some instances that we actually
have had looked at with legal
because of some incentives that are out that you
are asked that, hey, if you take this incentive,
we expect. You to do this, but that is just under some of the
incentive plans. Not a regular hire. No.
Is it allowable, though, in your
conversations with Legal through the years? Is that something that is
permissible? We have not discussed it
under the realm of just regular hires to the city. So I
can't find that out. I'd have to discuss it more with Legal, but as I
said, we have used it with respect to incentive plans,
which are a little different because the incentive is a little bit more than
just coming on board. Thank you. Yes, sir. So I've dealt with that
on both sides. If you pay an incentive up front
and someone agrees to sign a non compete
and they leave to go to a competitor or whatever it is, then you have
the right to go back. But as the State of Texas is a strong right
to work place, good luck,
because it's not going to be enforceable.
Vice Mayor for Tim if you just indulge me. I think it's very important
that we understand that retention is
going to be something that's a factor here in the city.
Okay. And we have employees that are here,
and as we are hiring, we have to
keep the employees that are here in the city.
We have to make them feel
like they are wanted so that they no longer want to
leave the city. I think it's very important to us
as a city that we invest, and we are doing that
within the Human Resources Department in training
for our managers and supervisors. It's very
important because in the statistical data that I
have looked at, a lot of people don't leave because of money.
They leave because of their supervisors and managers.
And it's very important that we make an investment
in training. I have a new Chief Financial I'm sorry,
a new Chief Learning Officer that's here that has set up a very robust
program. And we are just looking forward to training our
managers and supervisors to help with
understanding and being more empathetic as their managers
and supervisors, making sure that they understand how to deal with
the employees so we don't have that revolving door.
Yes, sir. Council Member Pollard on the
incentive part. So, the City of Houston, we have so
many attractions,
events, all types of
things that come to our city that we as a city are
a part of, and we could probably package together
as some type of incentive for employees, whether it's going
to certain different attractions, events,
sporting games, concerts, whatever. Right. The city of
Houston, I think, should leverage our partnership with a
lot of these different entities, whether it's Houston first, whether it's
the different sporting venues or whatever,
so that we can find as many perks to
work for. The city of Houston. That as a company,
we're able to offer you packages
to where you may be eligible for this, that, and or third, for you,
your family, or whoever. Right. Just like if you're in the
private sector, they're going to try to think of as many perks as possible to
lure you into wanting to work for them. But we, as a City
of Houston, we have partnerships with everybody, right? And even
as council members, we always get all types of invitations
and all types of different ways in which we can engage
and partake in the things that Houston has to offer. It would be great
to leverage our ability as a city with all the
different entities across the board, to be able to
have packages in place through HR, to where people who
work for the city are eligible to be able to go to some of these
things as well, to make their jobs and their
duties more attractive. Council Member Pollock, you are exactly
correct, and the HR department has already started that
we already have online. And maybe we need to make sure it's bigger
so that our employees see it. We already have a lot of partnerships
with the Rockets, the Texans for Discounts.
And we actually have on our website a City of Houston's discount
page that shows employees of the City of
Houston about those perks. Now, do we need to
do more? We are trying to do more right now, and we
are leveraging everything that comes to us with reference to
giving our employees discounts from taking the kids to the different
circuses and those type things. So we'll just make it bigger on our
web page. But we are that's great to hear. All right, thank you. We are.
Okay, we have four public speakers.
The first we'll go to is Mr. Doug Smith.
Doug,
star six.
Come on, Doug. You know the gig.
Okay. Jason Oliver. Jason, just come to this mic right here,
sir. Thank you.
I just want to say thank you and congratulations on the
on the paid leave. That's really exciting. And I know it's something
that I've been hearing is really good for the city.
First, something the Finance Department kind of pushed
us toward you all was a question about a
comparative analysis of employee pay. Has HR done
such a comparative analysis on employee pay across city departments?
If so, where can we find it and what needs have you identified?
And then I have one other question that comes from page seven.
How was that one and a half million for higher Houston youth decided?
And then what outcomes can we anticipate from significantly increasing
that funding? I care a lot about youth programming. That's really important to
me. And so trying to think about how we can expand higher Houston youth
and really kind of build on that, because that 1.5 million
has been static for a couple of years now, at least.
So let me start with your first question, which I
believe was in reference to the comparative the comparative
pay analysis. So per the financial policy yes,
we just completed that analysis.
So we will be doing a presentation to this
council in the next two months. So we did
it on fire, police and municipal employees.
That has been completed. And now we will do
a presentation as per the financial policy to council,
and that will be made available. Okay. All right, with reference
to higher Houston youth, and I believe it was council
member was it council member Green that actually started
the 1.5 million for talking
about the higher Houston youth. And so that has been something that
has been in the budget for a long time.
The administration would have to raise that 1.5
million. We accepted what was given to us.
Of course, we would be glad to do more with
more, but that has just been what
has been allotted for the youth,
for the city since the institution of
higher Houston youth. And what outcomes could we expect from increasing that
funding? Well, right now we have been
able, by bringing higher Houston youth into the city's budget,
we have been able to increase the number of people of
youth that could come in and work here at the city. So when
we started, we were right at like a little over 400.
Now we're actually able, because it's in house, to bring in
500 and therefore also bring in
the coaches. We have nine coaches. We believe it's important
that the youth are actually taught how
to, when they go out there, what they have to do.
So we go one step further by actually
having them coming to class, actually showing them what's
expected of them. So that can only be bigger
as our funding increases. Because the most important thing is that
children and youth learn by example. So we have to be able
to teach them to reach them. Okay. Okay.
Sarah Blanding, 1 minute,
please. 1 second.
I'd love to see how you okay, I have a couple of
questions. You've kind of answered them some way, but I just want to open the
floor to fill in. What are the
city's greatest staffing needs as you see them?
Oh, no, it wasn't okay. What are the city's greatest staffing needs
as you see them? And what would you need not
just working within your current limitations, but let's talk
about an ideal world to increase staffing and
retention to fully meet the needs of the city of Houston. And then
along with that is our temporary employee expenditures are much
higher than in previous years. I know to
some extent you've probably already answered that. Why do you think that is?
And how can we increase retention among city employees? And I'd love to
hear the answer. Not just like working with the loaves and fishes you have,
but if somebody performed a miracle and you actually had what you needed to feed
the crowd. Okay,
let me say that any entity,
city government, you are always going to
need more funding at the end
of the day, the city's budget is what we have. And like you say,
if we were given more money, I'm sure we'd have more people.
But we have services that we have to provide to
our residents. And what we have done is to ensure that we
are providing that level of services to
our residents, even with the staffing levels that we have.
Our city employees work hard. They work smart
too. And so it's very important, if I
got more money, the departments I
hire for the whole city, but at the end of the day, those departments
would have to specify the specific needs.
I'm the person that has to get the people in there. I don't
want to I don't want to speak for police and fire.
I can't, because the chiefs know what they need in
their departments. But I'm sure if any department
was the funding was increased, that would assist
them in getting more people. Again, our city
employees are stretched. I say every day,
they sacrifice what they make, they sacrifice the
hours that they have to be on duty, but they still
provide the level of servants to our residents.
So wish we could have more money, but until then, we're going
to keep providing what we need to provide.
Thank you. Mr Bernard Butler,
last public speaker. Thanks.
He'll ask five questions in a minute, though, right?
Thank you, Madam Director.
Thank you in your department, but apologies, ladies,
I'm going to speak through you.
Let's call a thing a thing. I concluded that all
city departments have been understaffed. It's no
longer about prioritization when
you receive less services. Every citizen should ask when they call.
Thank you. Every citizen should ask when they call a
department, are you fully staffed? Because this is
how communities like mine become underserved for
so long. It's not about great resignations, it's not about tightening
budgets, it's not even about COVID These things just
exposed a situation that existed.
And I will say, at the end of the day, we're citizens too.
But when it comes to where everything
shows up, by the time we get there too
many priorities, but we're already way behind.
Thank you. Thank you.
And directors, thank you very much for your time and your presentation.